good morning john aliens i love aliens
and there's lots of reasons to
especially in fiction adventure and
danger and the unknown and
self-reflection and mystery and
revelation but the thing i'm talking
about here
is real aliens which is a very different
thing and i should start out by saying
that i think that
life elsewhere in the universe is a
physical inevitability even if the
galaxy were not inconceivably huge which
it is the chemical system that is life
obeys the laws of kinetics and
thermodynamics and while it is possibly
the coolest most
interesting thing it's not magical
intelligent life
does not seem inevitable in the same way
it just seems extraordinarily likely in
statistics there's something called the
mediocrity principle basically if you
have a sample size of one
chances are that that is from the most
common data set and to some extent we
have pulled
one solar system out of the hat and it
has intelligent life on it it has
several species of intelligent life now
there are some reasons to think that
like our version of intelligent life as
it exists right now on this planet is
not super common but zero reasons to
think it's unique but that's all preface
the thing i want to talk about is why do
people like me who have an understanding
of how
discovery works how science works seem
to never think that extremely unusual
things
are caused by alien and that's relevant
right now because there are these
unclassified videos and
there's a congressional report coming
out about them and we do not know what
they are but
there are going to be and have been many
times things that we
really do not understand this has
happened a lot in the history of our
species and it's often the first
step on the path to discovery we don't
know exactly what's going on we make
guesses we test them that's how we end
up knowing more things and being able to
do more things that's how we ended up
with covert vaccines and smartphones and
in-depth knowledge of the big bang but
also when you are inside this world you
know that there are a lot of big
mysteries right now that are
totally unexplained we don't know what
dark matter is but it is
most of the stuff but also we don't know
why anything exists
at all like why there's matter in the
universe that's a mystery we don't know
how life started on earth also like we
don't know why we sleep we don't know
where we yawn but here's the thing
almost every mystery could be answered
with the word
alien and that makes it a certain kind
of bad explanation
we want to understand things that we
don't understand that's totally normal
and one way to do that
is to find an explanation that will
explain
everything there's a fairly new version
of this which is that our universe is a
simulation and whenever you see
something that doesn't make sense
that's a glitch in the simulation now to
me there are two big problems with
explanations that can explain anything
first
every time we've ever had something go
from mystery to not a mystery anymore
it has not been explained by something
that could explain everything we've had
some biggies that have explained a lot
like natural selection or quantum
mechanics but they haven't explained
everything like for example those two
things don't do a great job of
explaining each other and the second
thing this is really important
i don't think it's not aliens i think we
don't know what it is
it's really important to be able to say
that we don't know what something is
without trying to immediately explain it
whenever we do that whenever we
encounter something that's completely
unexplained and we immediately try to
explain it with some idea from our heads
it's not based on data and observation
and critical thinking it's based on our
biases and on our confusion
and on defaulting to something that
could explain anything
things to know about these unidentified
aerial phenomena they are moving against
the wind they are detected by multiple
sensors including human eyes they are
moving in ways that known aircraft do
not move are they aircraft they might be
they might not be
the wrong thing to do is to dismiss
these things as a joke just because like
everybody's saying aliens in science and
in life you have to follow the
interesting and and this stuff's really
interesting
it's weird and honestly i'm a little
worried that like the legitimate
interestingness of this
gets overwhelmed by the conspiracy
theories and the just
wild flagrant guessing about sexy things
that could explain lots of other things
but most importantly preferring a
conclusion
is the exact thing that scientists are
taught to avoid investigating potential
explanations
absolutely figuring out new ways to
gather more data 100
but focusing on explanations that could
kind of explain anything
have so far not helped us explain
anything john i'll see you on tuesday